how do you overcome depression I'm going
to try to answer that question on
today's episode of lunch and earn so our
recent got asks a question for one of my
new YouTube subscribers love you guys
Diego Acosta who wrote in the say Evan I
want to thank you for this video I just
subscribed your channel last Sunday and
you really do exceptional work trying to
help others thanks Diego appreciate that
how do you overcome depression the last
months have been a rollercoaster for me
a lot of things going on from divorce
and death of close family members I feel
like I can give more to life I don't
like the way I look what I eat where I
work I'm trying to go back and get my
wife and my daughter but every morning I
try to hear motivational videos that
help me for minutes or hours and then
I'm back to that poor performance and
everything in my life what would you do
what would your advice be how do I find
what I love and not feel stuck in life
Diego this is a really heavy message and
I really feel for you and what's going
on in your life and how everything is
kind of crumbling around you and I've
got three bits of advice that I hope
will help number one is raise your
standards every time that I've seen a
major improvement in my life every time
I've jumped up to the next level it's
because I've raised my standards it's
because I've changed my mindset it's
because I've made a list of the things
that I'm no longer willing to accept and
that's to start right if you're down
deep in that hole you've got to set some
new standards for yourself of the things
you are no longer willing to accept in
terms of everything in your life the
people you hang out with the the type of
work that you do the types of food that
you eat it's a different and mindset
where you're not now the guy who's just
trying to lose 10 pounds you're the kind
of guy who has already lost that 10
pounds what does that person look like
right who is the person that your wife
fell in love with and married and it's
not you doing a couple little things
it's totally changing yourself to be
that guy right raising your standards
for what you are no longer willing to
accept around you and also within you
number two is find your passion you've
got to do something that makes you come
alive it'll be such a amazing feeling
for you once you can figure that out
because
you've done and experienced a lot in
your life to this point that has been
the exact opposite that's just like
beating you in the ground and you need
to find that thing that you love doing
that brightens you up that makes you
come alive and there's a funny thing
that happens when you are doing work
that you love that is meaningful that is
earning you money that you are excited
about that has a ripple effect right
work has a ripple effect if you come
home from your your business or your job
and you are upset and angry and stressed
out that has a huge effect on the rest
of your life right that impacts your
relationship that impacts the food you
eat that impacts your health level
everything where if you love what you're
doing and you're coming back home
excited and feeling grateful and being
happy with what you've contributed that
day then that has a positive impact on
your health and the food you eat and
your relationship with your wife and
your your child right so you want to do
work that makes you come alive and it's
not gonna happen every single day right
I mean I love what I do but there are
days still that I have that are bad so
it's not gonna be perfect ever but if
you are going to many days waking up and
going and do something that you don't
love doing then you need to switch you
got to find something that you love and
number three is start a morning routine
I'm big on routines I love what I find
they set me up for the day really well
find the thing that you need to start
your day that makes you get excited that
gives you energy that make you feel
grateful and that sets you up for
success for that day so the reason why I
started the end special series that I
record every morning is because I wanted
something to give me that little shot to
give me that feeling of thinking bigger
and reaching for higher dreams and
studying success and how can I pour that
into my business so I'm not going place
it and boring and just doing the same
thing over and over and over again you
need to create that routine for yourself
so that you've set those high standards
right first step we're setting our high
standards now you are doing something
that you love or exploring and try to
find that and then you need that morning
routine so you can get back to that
every day because you could be one day
on a high you watching one original
video or whatever it is and you're all
excited and then the next day you're
starting from scratch and so at least
for me I find that so I'm starting from
scratch and
every single day and I need to have that
morning routine to get me set up for
success do I want to address the the
wife I feel like I should but I feel
like I'm not an expert all right in
regards to getting your wife back and
and your daughter I don't pretend to be
an expert in that field and
relationships and I almost didn't want
to record this answer but I felt like
I'm just gonna share my thoughts and
hopefully that that might add some
meaning and value for you one of the
things I found in relationships is you
need to love yourself first you need to
be happy with who you are and not look
to the other person to always bring you
up where I've seen a lot of failed
relationships you're always depending on
that other person to make you feel good
and you're not ever happy with yourself
and so that's a start right you have to
love what you're doing right you have to
be happy with yourself as human being
the other thing that I found is when it
gets to divorce stage they're probably
times along that path where where she
was trying to help you where she was
trying to believe in you or she was
trying to support you where she was
trying to find ways to make it work and
you just kind of shut the door on her
and so it can be hard to come back from
that right where it's like shut shut
shut shut shut shut over and over and
over and over again to then open the
door and show that you you become a
changed person and so if you really
wanted to get her back my honest opinion
without any factual kind of knowledge of
research would be one I wouldn't let her
go I would I would continue to stay in
touch I would continue to tell her that
you love her that you're thinking about
her not in a desperate way you know one
of things I find really helpful in the
mornings I have a quick notes of
gratitude and I'll send a note to my
wife just either a happy face or I love
you or just something to start my day
off with gratitude I would make a
conscious effort to think about her in a
positive way and share what you love
about her
and that you're thinking about her so
it's not a desperate way but it's a it's
an honest kind of heartfelt way and then
I think the biggest thing for her is
gonna be showing that you have actually
changed because it's easy to say you're
gonna change and you've probably said
that you were gonna change and then you
didn't and so now she doesn't trust that
opinion you have to actually show that
you're changing you're showing that hey
I've lost 15 pounds I'm eating healthier
I'm working out I like taking our
daughter out to places I've switched the
job that I'm at I've started my own
business whatever it is right like when
you actually feel happy in what you're
doing
that'll radiate out and she'll be able
to feel it if you're staying in touch
and showing I think she needs action to
see that you've actually changed so I
kind of ran out there at the bed at the
end and I'm still a little bit hesitant
about publishing it but I feel like
we're gonna put it up so good luck I
feel for you ice you know that was one
of the hardest messages that I got
coming in from one of the YouTube
subscribers and I really hope that it
will help you turn your life around so
for everybody watching if you guys have
some extra advice that might be helpful
in this situation from your own personal
experience I love for you to share it as
well because I think that might help him
as well leave in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon